[Applause]
break down the difference
between hgh testosterone and steroids
okay so those three things can't
necessarily
be calibrated they're operating in
different scales so like
steroid is just like a designated term
to a group of hormones we have hormones
al have you ever done steroids i took
testosterone pills
back in the day oh like the
over-the-counter stuff yeah yeah
shout out to akash hold on though and so
here's the thing
and there i don't know if it was
somebody who do that but we talked
testosterone over the counter you can
just buy
back in the day and like it was called
like methylated testosterone
and it was like it was in the little
glass cabinets right that stuff
your parents would have given you that
you would have had some issues
so you can kind of it's a wash they
didn't give you hgh whatever but it they
didn't give you that either because that
stuff was pretty lethal
like i know guys that had like are on
kidney dialysis right now because of the
stuff they were buying over the counter
back oh [ __ ]
they're like they're people in
competitive sports that they were
abusing it they were going
super hard it's not a those particular
compounds were not hard to abuse because
they were so potent and so harsh
okay so the vehicle of delivery of like
those types of drugs
is gonna broadly dictate the side
effects so most people think that
like injectable performance-enhancing
drugs are
more dangerous but they're actually more
so they
and again the whole biochemistry thing
they we know you're not about chemistry
not holding you to that sure
asking these questions as a workout guru
yeah which
wow what did you were you asking
yesterday why am i not like a tick tock
influencer or something like that that's
a worse
accusation yeah
yeah so a lot of people like oh well
right you know you inject heroin
that's bad for you yeah foreign that's
obviously bad for you
and the pills must be a little bit more
innocuous it must be
easier for you when actually the way
your body has to process and break down
these hormones through that vehicle of
delivery is
usually much harsher liver kidneys right
so they're fairly liver toxic so it's
doing damage to a lot more [ __ ] than
yeah it's just it's got to go through
these things to get in and be
like bioactive in the body right so it's
kind of your original question so
with steroid testosterone and hcp is
there another one
i mean there's there's hundreds of like
what they call designer drugs but is
there another like
umbrella that i'm not talking about
right so let's let's uh let's identify
the umbrellas first yeah so the two ones
that i think we've been talking about
the most so there's
steroids and peptides okay they're both
hormones right so they're steroid
hormones and peptide hormones
and those are different those are
different they're different primarily in
there
why do we never hear anybody talk about
peptides so it's emerging it's emerging
now
in from a recovery standpoint oddly
enough
that i mean compounds like bpc157 tb500
um ghrp6 all of these things
they sound like logan kept saying over
and over and then we went over to
whitney and she was doing it too the
peptides thing they would shoot right
into their stomach
subcutaneous or so i've done peptides so
i did
bpc157 and i directly injected that into
my tricep tendon
and i did subcutaneous um so peptides
are like gray areas
some some uh professional sports have a
ban against them they're difficult to
test for but peptides
so let's go after the umbrellas peptides
you could be yes there's bpc157 this
tb500 all of this stuff but gh and
insulin
or hgh and insulin are also considered
peptide hormones
they're much more complex and oftentimes
just have to be administered
through injection because because they
are so
complex you can't as you orally ingest
them you can't really break that down
into anything that's bioactive in the
body
metformin is like a little bit of a
different process metformin is like
insulin
right but it's it's an oral insulin
blood glucose management thing so
umbrella terms peptides and then
steroids
right and they're both hormones so this
category of like
steroid hormones then that's where most
of what you hear in the news and
performance enhancing drugs is based
around
much easier to test for way more
compounds been around for longer
peptides
really emerging new kind of market not
necessarily in
performance enhancement in the way that
we think about like jose canseco
yeah baseball like barry bonds's giant
[ __ ] head like
peptides are really more based around
recovery of like tendons and
vascular tissue so what makes your head
big just to
really yeah so that's an interesting one
gh
hgh at high enough dose triggers a
compound
in your body if i'm not mistaken called
igf-1 insulin growth factor one
that's when hgh starts to help not just
put on
muscle which at low dose it doesn't
really do that well right right so hgh
isn't necessarily anabolic in one of its
primary properties anabolic is
like the defining term of growing right
yeah
muscle tissue primarily but once we get
to the level that we have enough gh
circulating that it
triggers this igf-1 yeah that i think
then starts to stimulate growth of
everything
i got it you're the blue guy from x-men
beast
yeah oh it's so funny you're beast
that's what it is
so i figured it out and then yeah so
what happened like or like hulk you're
like bruce banner but like when he just
goes i'll just be hulk the whole time
right yeah yeah yeah yeah but like
you're a nerd but like you're [ __ ]
jacked
right yeah yeah this is i don't i don't
i don't does you shouldn't be like this
i don't hate that you're like an
astronaut
yeah yeah it doesn't make any sense so
just breaking [ __ ] in the spaceship
so but here's the thing we talked about
akash earlier yeah i just want to make
his head normal-sized so can we give him
hgh
what can we do so this is kind of my own
theory but yeah so they give it to kids
because when you're growing you have
this thing called like growth
plates in your long bones that's right
and sometimes you'd break your
you ever have a friend who like broke
their leg and then the growth plate was
affected and it wouldn't grow as long
it's called the salter harris fractures
salter salter harris and that's when
they break the plate and because of the
growth plate fracture their leg or arm
or whatever it is and grow yeah yeah
okay okay
yeah so that's like there's there's
gradients of salter harris fractures but
that's it so
as a kid before those growth plates are
closed if we can
introduce hgh then it can increase oh
wow
once a growth place closed now it's done
but there are bones in your body that
don't have growth plates right like your
long bones like your tibia
your head your skull that's what i'm
thinking and that that could be common
knowledge i just haven't read too much
into it but like
people who get accused of like just
having like the giant dome
yeah like the berry bomb the berry bonds
yeah yeah okay so
so uh peptides are more used for
recovery
okay so this is where it gets trickier
yeah yeah yeah okay i know right it's
hard but this gives
us the most like basic like you can you
can't you can't dude so
why would whitney cummings be doing
peptides it's not to get jacks
probably i mean skin hair right nails
ah so all of that there's like a youth
serum in it
i've always heard that about hgh it's
good for anti-aging
yeah that's a thing no i don't know to
what degree like it's boner's hair like
if we go to hgh but i heard it you get
like horny more often
your hair is thicker the hair i've heard
the nails
i mean it's all i guess would trigger
stimulate like collagen
deposition or collagen formation in your
blood so that might be
part of it um a lot of not aging is just
it's not necessarily growth sometimes
but the absence of death
right so if we can stop these cells from
breaking down
that might be a fundamental difference
yeah you're gonna certain things like i
think what is it like collagen just
stops reproducing at the same rate
yeah if you could increase the
production or at least maintain the
production of it
right deterioration okay that makes
sense okay so
yeah go ahead go go so i'm just trying
to understand more or less how each one
is used
uh so and again i know these are blanket
statements but like peptides for example
if a guy just wants to get absolutely
[ __ ] shredded ripped is he on
peptides
so peptide so if you want to get
shredded ripped probably
like human growth hormone is in the mix
at some point it doesn't have to be
so it's a cocktail people are using more
than one of these i would imagine
so and there's not a specific category
for each one
there is but it gets complicated because
people are crossing
both of those umbrella terms give me the
most basic easy to understand one and
then we'll build on that like what is
the just
what is the rudimentary hey you want to
gain more muscle
you just want to do this what are you
taking so the simple one about gaining
muscle the process of like becoming a
quote-unquote anabolic
insulin is your most anabolic hormone
there is so people are just shooting
insulin
yeah i mean it's not necessarily the
safest way to do it
why orders of magnitude it's it's
probably
the most if not the most dangerous drug
that people take
because it's like if your body doesn't
have enough available blood glucose
to start to store that insulin still
work in and you actually store a decent
amount of
blood glucose in your brain so this is
no different than any diabetic that
would go into like
some sort of coma coma right so like a
diet give yourself a
oh it's not having if you look if you
insulin absolutely
holy [ __ ] oh if you look at the
bodybuilding community that's a that's
not a rampant problem because
it is usually hopefully approached with
those who partake in that yeah with a
certain level of trepidation a certain
level of respect because it is
can be a catastrophic so insulin is his
own category that's the quickest way to
get big
very dangerous very dangerous also a
peptide it's a peptide it's a peptide in
its category of its umbrella term yeah
gotcha
okay peptides word is still out people
are starting to dabble in them not
people who necessarily want to be jacked
right
but there are some ways where it could
uh increase really new cool frontier
on like regenerative medicine it's for
regenerative
regen generative okay i've heard that
about aging is just cell death and
they're getting better at
slowing down so it's like telomeres
that's probably why whitney would want
to do it yes
right okay this makes more sense in
doing it in i guess small enough doses
where you're getting that benefit but
it's not affecting these other
and then give me the worst case scenario
with a peptide again because the worst
case scenario with insulin is you go
into diabetic coma
worst case scenario with peptide is so
yeah i mean peptides seeing
more towards this recovery anti-aging
thing yeah you don't really know
okay so very new frontier stuff the guy
william seeds dr seeds is the head of
the peptide society he was said to have
cured remember brady cut his hand in the
super bowl like i don't know however
many years ago okay kind of a low-key
thing
okay and he got a medical exemption to
get treated and
he had like a fairly large laceration in
his throwing i remember oh yeah
i think they used some sort of like
electrophoresis with this peptide and
got them back
like crazy fast like there's been just
to give context
they do rat studies on this compound
called bpc157
complete purposeful go in cut the wrap
pcl which the posterior collateral
ligament of your knee is your largest
ligament of the knee
everyone knows about the acl because it
gets a lot of press pcl is way bigger
they go in and cut it they leave one
knee untreated they
treat one knee just with the bpc157 they
calibrate for
milligrams per body weight [ __ ] thing
grew back
that's crazy the [ __ ] thing grew back
that's amazing that's
great it is like but we don't know
overdoing bpc157 we don't
know what those side effects look like
because we're still kind of in this new
front
i'm willing to find out right insulin
peptides right
next one yeah yeah they're under the
same thing but okay
um testosterone yeah
steroid hormone so testosterone is a
steroid
right and it is just increasing this
thing that already exists in your body
right and the benefit is increase in
muscle mass
energy so i would break it down in
simplest forms i would say it increases
like muscle protein synthesis so you
still have to work out in order to get
that absolutely
yeah but you're going to get more return
out of that workout than you would get
regularly so if i do 20 push-ups without
test
and i do 20 push-ups with testosterone
maybe it feels like i did 40.
yeah i don't i wouldn't go i don't want
to give you the exact numbers i'm just
trying to make this digestible for like
um
i think it'll it allows there's a
neurological component to it that goes
under look
we're sorry overlooked so it'll likely
allow you to increase your output as
well oh
it allows me to do more push-ups and do
40 push-ups because i can now i can
build money
and then does it help recover quicker
that's what muscle protein synthesis is
gotcha so i can do more right because
it's giving me more energy and more
strength it might be like a uh like a
myelination like a neurological thing
some way that's
transmission um kind of so now now let's
subdivide
this might help yeah let's subdivide
real quick real quick just uh so so the
reason why recovery is
uh important in this is because muscle
growth is recovery right we just for the
average person we tear apart the muscle
more or less yeah basic terms tear apart
the muscle
it regrows stronger now i have big
bigger muscles yeah
roughly right so if we can tear apart
the muscle
more and it grows back even faster
you're going to get these gains if this
is the most likely
more mechanical tension i think that's
how i would be comfortable with that
sure yeah okay so that's testosterone
hgh
so yeah hgh kind we kind of discussed
earlier a peptide hormone
falls under peptides with insulin with
these new experimental grades yeah
area research peptides like bpc and all
that stuff hgh
increases glycolysis sorry decreases
glycolysis decreases your ability to
process carbohydrates over time
fairly dose dependent it seems yep right
so dose dependent in the sense that it's
like okay
um there's certain thresholds that we
reach at lower doses where physiological
processes become more prominent then as
we increase the doses we actually start
to trigger and reach thresholds of
other physiological events right so it's
like
you know if you're taking a lower amount
this is usually probably the more the
longevity play like if you were to go to
a
anti-aging clinic all these people go
give you a little bit of gh
a little bit yeah and then as you go
into like the professional bodybuilding
world
this is when foreheads are growing this
is when the growth hormone is likely
starting to assist in the anabolic
process right through the mechanism like
igf-1
this is just my very very peripheral
understanding of this stuff
okay so gh insulin peptide all of that
now the thing the interesting thing to
think to break down is the steroid
category
as steroids get ranked between what's
called an anabolic property and an
androgenic property okay
so anabolic growth right we kind of
talked about that with insulin yeah
androgenic is like secondary secondary
sex characteristics primarily
androgynous as you can't tell what sex
they are right so androgens
is like the biggest thing that people i
don't say look for
but this and we may have actually
discussed this in the gym one day
is kind of like this is where like the
roid rage thing comes in there are
particular drugs that are more
androgenic and that's going to start to
promote
more of like that secondary sex
characteristics so like with
male 1 uh not necessarily more so like
aggression oh that's a female trait
uh no no androgen higher androgens would
be more because these are male
hormones right these are male
predominants i'm just saying but if you
also get titties and you also get
smaller balls and then you're also
aggressive that might be a female we're
turning
i think that's uh that's correlation not
causation
right okay like highly highly androgenic
highly androgenic i think it's turning
us into women
it's probably environmental plastics and
and environmental estrogens are probably
doing that at
scale way more than the use of also that
also that
but i think that the female
characteristics that are
accompanied with the testosogenic like
they're called yeah the androgenic ones
are are are aggression being
unreasonable
road rage growing titties and growing
smaller balls women have smaller balls
the smallest balls none
right and they also are aggressive and
they you know road rage and they'll yell
for no reason
so you dig your own grave don't worry
i'm saying i gotta go home after this
[ __ ]
and titties and titties it's turning us
into a woman but it's called androgenic
though
androgenic yeah why is it called through
genic it's not androgenic
yeah and the
first three unreasonable he said andrew
jennings no
you said andra andrew andra andra
you